okay hier ist der terminplan für die heutige
sitzung
zuerst eine kurze präsentation des
lehrprojekts dann das didaktische
konzept
kursplan
terminplan und zum schluss frage und diskussion also der erste punkt unserer präsentation ähm es ist ein lehrprojekt und eine zusammenarbeit zwischen lmu münchen und
etihar zürich es ist  finanziert durch e-learning
am ind, einem neuen Projekt, das
sowohl neue Medien als auch
berühmte Universitäten zusammenbringt,
und
dieses
Seminar zielt darauf ab, internationale
interdisziplinäre Perspektiven auf
künstliche Intelligenz zu entwickeln. Es zielt auch darauf ab
, Online-
Lehrtechnologien wie Blogs, Apps, Wikis,
Online-Quiz zu integrieren und zu kombinieren  Live-Streams und sogar
YouTube-Kanäle, also sehen Sie, dass
in dieses Seminar eine Menge neuer Medien integriert sind,
und es ist auch in gewisser Weise ein
Experiment, und wir werden sehen,
ob es funktioniert oder nicht. Ich hoffe, es wird
funktionieren, und ich bin ziemlich optimistisch,
also lass uns gehen  zum didaktischen konzept
wie sie schon gesehen haben gibt es eine
seminarwebseite ai
perspektive
s.net schau es dir an ich finde es
interessant ähm es gibt ähm gibt es einen Blog
es gibt auch ein wiki
ähm es gibt ein
paar quizzes wir werden ähm im laufe
dieses seminars werden wir neue quizzes hochladen
damit du immer
deine testen kannst  Wissen Sie Ihr Verständnis
und diese Quiz werden auch
für Apps verfügbar sein. Ich werde Ihnen jetzt etwas mehr darüber erzählen. Es
gibt also eine eigene App
für dieses Seminar, die für Android-
und Apple-Smartphones ist. Sie heißt
Philocast-App.
Hier ist das
Bild aus dem
Android-Store und  Hier ist das Bild
aus dem Apple Store, es ist kostenlos, also
können Sie es herunterladen, wenn Sie möchten, und Sie
werden auch andere Inhalte in dieser
App finden. Es gibt Quiz, wie Sie sehen können.
Dieser Hinweis zeigt an, dass es ein Quiz
gibt, an dem Sie teilnehmen können
flieg sozusagen
also schau es dir einfach an probier es aus alle zoom
sitzungen werden aufgezeichnet
da dies hier ist aber nicht die diskussion daher
ist uns der datenschutz sehr wichtig
außerdem werden die
sitzungen auf dem youtube kanal zur verfügung gestellt
Filocast, das inzwischen mehr als 4000
Abonnenten hat,
Sie können auch nur Philocast eingeben,
und Sie werden es bald finden,
und es dient dazu, unseren Beitrag zu dokumentieren,
damit Sie es später ansehen können oder
wenn Sie keine Zeit haben, an dem
Seminar teilzunehmen, ist es nicht  Problem
, gehen wir weiter zum
Kursplan
und unseren
Philosophen, die wir
besprechen werden, und ich übergebe Arno, dass er
uns sagen kann, was es mit diesen
Texten und Philosophen
auf
sich hat  ähm
ja ich glaube ich
will jetzt nicht direkt
auf die beiden philosophen eingehen
und deswegen nehme ich es
etwas komplizierter
ich meine
warum
wollen wir
in diesem seminar künstliche intelligenz diskutieren
und evtl. ist es speziell für
studenten von  das eter
möglicherweise nicht so sehr für studenten des
alamo hängt ein wenig davon ab, was man
studiert,
es ist mehr oder weniger
sofort klar, warum wir
an einer universität über künstliche intelligenz diskutieren müssen und t  zwischen
verschiedenen Disziplinen,
aber ich denke, zumindest aus meiner Sicht gibt
es zwei äh
verschiedene Möglichkeiten, um zu begründen, sagen
wir, warum wir KI bei der künstlichen Intelligenz diskutieren sollten,
und
einer ist, dass wir
das bei vielen vielen sicher problemlos beobachten können
anwendungsbereiche digitaler
technologien
that technologies spezifische technologien,
die im bereich der ai entwickelt wurden, werden
mehr und mehr angewendet und
verändern
die art und weise, wie wir digitale werkzeuge nutzen,
verändern die art und Weise, wie wir kommunizieren, indem
wir beispielsweise die art und weise, wie wir wissenschaft
betreiben, verändern  die Art und Weise verändern, wie wir
mit Computern interagieren, wie wir unsere
Autos fahren und viele, viele verschiedene Dinge, so dass
unsere Wissenschaften
KI im umfassenderen Bereich der digitalen Transformation unserer Kultur und unserer Gesellschaft eine immer wichtigere Rolle spielen,
so dass dies der Fall ist  Ein Aspekt ist der riesige
Prozess der digitalen Transformation und
die spezifische Rolle der Technologien,
die in diesem Bereich entwickelt wurden  künstlicher
intelligenz
der zweite aspekt warum ich das
interessant finde oder warum wir denken ich hoffe ich kann
york in dieser hinsicht einbeziehen
warum wir denken das es sinnvoll ist im moment
über künstliche intelligenz zu diskutieren
liegt daran das die künstliche
intelligenzforschung im moment
an einem ist  bestimmten Punkt in ihrer eigenen Geschichte,
weil künstliche
Intelligenz gewissermaßen ein Gebiet mit einer bestimmten
und spezifischen komplizierten Geschichte erforscht,
das
in den letzten 10 oder 20 Jahren eine spezifische interessante Wendung erlebt hat,
nämlich dass ein spezifischer Ansatz
, den wir Deep Learning nennen können,
oder dass wir  Man kann
künstliche neuronale Netze nennen, dass dieser
spezifische Ansatz unglaublich
erfolgreich war
und sehr oft die
Grundlage vieler dieser Technologien bildet, viele
dieser Werkzeuge, die wir in unserer täglichen
Praxis finden,
so dass
in der Geschichte der Forschung im Bereich der künstlichen
Intelligenz
langsam, aber auf breiter Basis etwas Neues geschah  Bereich mit einer
großen Auswirkung möglicherweise nur in den letzten 10
oder 20 Jahren
, das
ist von a  besonderes Interesse, weil es ein
sehr spezifischer Ansatz ist, den
wir in der Forschung zu künstlicher Intelligenz beobachten können
oder wie er oft sehr oft
als maschinelles Lernen oder insbesondere
Deep Learning bezeichnet wird, also gibt es zwei Kontexte,
den großen Kontext, den viel
umfassenderen Kontext der digitalen
Transformation
und den anderen Kontext  mehr
mit der Geschichte der künstlichen
Intelligenzforschung und einer bestimmten neuen
Technologie verbunden ist, die sich
in den letzten Jahren als sehr erfolgreich erwiesen hat, wissen Sie,
und die
Struktur des Seminars würde ich ein wenig erklären,
ja, sagen wir mal eine Arbeitsdefinition
von künstlich  Intelligenzforschung,
was ist das,
ich weiß es nicht genau, und möglicherweise fällt
mir jedes Mal eine Definition ein,
wenn jemand nein sagt, das ist
keine korrekte Definition,
es ist anders
wie die
Umsetzung in intelligentes Verhalten
auf der Grundlage von com
putationale prozesse das ist ein arbeitsprozess eine
arbeitsdefinition die ich als ausgangspunkt vorschlagen würde
also die umsetzung von
künstlichem verhalten was auch immer das
genau ist auf der basis von rechnerischen
prozessen
und die erste frage die damit verbunden ist was
diese art von arbeit mit sich bringt  Ich habe mit der
Arbeitsdefinition
um
in gewisser Weise die Frage impliziert,
was künstlich ist,
was intelligentes Verhalten ist
und
was genau
eine Maschine sein könnte, eine Rechenmaschine
, die
in gewisser Weise ein Verhalten zeigt oder ausführt
, das wir als intelligent bezeichnen würden,
und der erste Teil
und  Sie sehen hier die Daten und die beiden
Philosophen oder die beiden Theoretiker,
Mathematiker, Philosophen. Im Fall
von Turing ist es ziemlich kompliziert,
was genau er ist oder was er war,
weil er so viele interessante Dinge getan hat,
aber diese beiden Texte hier
von Alan Curing und Chong  sir
kann sich in gewisser Weise auf die Frage konzentrieren,
was oder wie können wir Maschinen nennen
oder wie können wir  Nennen
wir Maschinen intelligent Nehmen wir an,
sind die Maschinen intelligent
oder ist ihr Verhalten intelligent und warum
glauben wir, dass dieses spezifische Verhalten
von etwas intelligent genannt werden könnte,
so dass
die ersten beiden
Texte in gewisser Weise
die Frage ansprechen,
wie wir etwas als intelligentes
Verhalten bezeichnen können
und
sie verfolgen völlig unterschiedliche Ansätze.
Turing ist in gewisser Weise ein Argument für
ähm
für eine Art von
Ja, es heißt Imitationsspiel, es ist eine
Art
ähm-
Szenario, in dem wir
versuchen könnten, zu entscheiden, bestimmte Kriterien
für die Entscheidung anzugeben, ob ein Verhalten
intelligent erscheint  oder nicht
und in gewisser weise argumentiert john cerl direkt
gegen
die art und Weise, wie turin versuchte, die frage zu formulieren,
wann
eine maschine oder ein verhalten, das wir
beobachten können, als intelligent bezeichnet werden könnte.
okay, das ist für mich ein bisschen
der erste
teil
, auf den ich gehe  zweiter Teil,
der
in gewisser Weise
auch mit der Frage verbunden ist, was
intelligentes Verhalten ist, denn
Sie wissen,
was Intelligenz ist,
es ist eine ziemlich offene Frage  Es ist möglich,
dass wir dieses Wort verwenden, und es
wurde sicherlich lange Zeit ohne Probleme verwendet
, aber
was ist Intelligenz? Es ist nicht so einfach
, genau zu spezifizieren, welche
Art von Leistungen, welche Art von
Aufgaben Sie lösen können, als
intelligent angesehen werden und welche Kunst
Das ist der Punkt, an dem die Geschichte
der künstlichen Intelligenzforschung
ein wenig ins Spiel kommt,
denn lange Zeit dachte oder teilte die künstliche
Intelligenzforschung
in gewisser Weise
die Prämisse,
dass
Intelligenz oder Intelligenz und
intelligentes
Verhalten mit Denken verbunden ist
und dann Denken war  sehr oft
als
logisches Denken verstanden,
so
dass man zum Beispiel Schlussfolgerungen ziehen kann,
logische Eingriffe
oder
dass man
intellektuelle Spiele wie Schach spielen kann,
also
eine sehr alte Vorstellung vom Verstand, dass das
Rechnen als
logisch ist, und das Befürchten, dass dies eine sehr alte
Vorstellung der modernen Philosophie ist  darüber, was es
heißt,
hier kombiniert zu denken,
wurde in der KI-Forschung in gewisser Weise kombiniert
mit dem Ziel,
was wir zeigen  Uld konstruieren, wenn wir
versuchen
, eine Maschine zu konstruieren, die
heute als intelligent angesehen werden könnte, also
versuchten Menschen oder ein Forscher versuchten,
Maschinen zu konstruieren, die logisch
denken oder Schach spielen können,
also war Schach so entscheidend
für die Geschichte der künstlichen
Intelligenz
einen Computer zu konstruieren, der
den besten menschlichen Schachspieler im Schach schlagen kann,
und das wurde schließlich erreicht. Ich glaube, es
war 1996
Deep Blue gegen Gary Kasparov
, das in gewisser Weise ein Ergebnis dieser
Art der KI-Forschung dieses Ansatzes der
KI-Forschung war
aber gleichzeitig ist etwas anderes
passiert und das hängt mit der
Erkenntnis zusammen,
dass ein anderer
Ansatz konzipiert wurde.
Die ersten
Anfänge waren viel älter, aber an ihrem
spezifischen Punkt wurde ein
Forscher von der
neurologischen Forschung über den visuellen
Kortex des Gehirns inspiriert
und sie begannen damit  sagen ok evtl.
wenn wir
eine intelligente maschine konstruieren wollen
sollte sie nicht
primär logisch denken oder sie
sollte nicht  nicht
primär schach spielen oder
so vielleicht ist es viel interessanter
eine maschine zu konstruieren die
objekte erkennen kann die objekte
sehen
kann die einen apfel erkennen kann
und
einen pfirsich oder so ähnlich
gleichgültigkeit gegenüber einem apfel
und das war sehr schwer für die  alter
Ansatz, aber es scheint, dass es
viel einfacher war, diese Art von
Aufgabe mit dem neuen Ansatz zu lösen, der auf
künstlichen neuronalen Netzen basiert,
die ihre Inspiration
von äh der
neurologischen Forschung über das menschliche oder
nichtmenschliche Gehirn bezogen,
also
ein ganz anderer
Ansatz  wurde erdacht
, das
nicht auf
ähm
nicht auf der Berechnung logischer
Interferenzen
oder der rechnerischen
Auswertung von Zügen im Schachspiel oder
ähnlichem basiert, sondern
auf
vielen vielen kleinen Prozessoren, die
in einer Art Netzwerk von Einzelprozessen interagieren,
wie das  Das Gehirn besteht aus vielen vielen
Einzelprozessen, die miteinander verknüpft sind
und durch das
Netzwerk ein Signal verarbeiten  nal
und das lernt die Art und Weise, wie es Prozesse
verarbeitet
und diese unterschiedlichen Ansätze werden
von Smolinski diskutiert.
Trifus und Enzenger sprechen
viel mehr den klassischen Ansatz an
, der sich auf das Schachspielen konzentrierte und
der sich auf logisches Denken konzentrierte.
Smolensky befasst sich viel mehr mit dem
neuen Paradigma und so weiter  mehr
und hat viel mehr im Sinn Dinge wie
Sehen,
Sehen von
Objekten,
also
was bedeutet es zu denken, kann
unterschiedliche Antworten geben,
und unterschiedliche Antworten auf diese Fragen
sind mit unterschiedlichen Ansätzen der
künstlichen Intelligenzforschung in den
letzten Jahrzehnten verbunden,
und es war ein Gehirn, das vom Gehirn inspiriert wurde
Ansatz, der sich als sehr erfolgreich erwiesen hat und
der heute
manchmal als Modell für das menschliche
Gehirn verwendet wird,
weil wir im Detail auch nicht
genau verstehen, wie das menschliche Gehirn
Signale verarbeitet,
so dass manchmal
die künstlichen Netzwerke zum
Verständnis verwendet werden oder als Werkzeug konzipiert sind
Modellierung als Modell für den natürlichen
Prozess im menschlichen Gehirn
und einige und ein Kerl  Wer
diese Art des
Verständnisses vorschlägt, ist Cameron Buckner, ein sehr
neuer Text vor zwei Jahren,
also sind dies die beiden ersten Blöcke und
der dritte Block
ist in gewisser Weise, oh nein, tut mir leid, ich bin nur okay,
genau
richtig, das sind die beiden ersten Blöcke und
da  wird sozusagen ein Zwischenblock
und nicht ganz der dritte Block
Anna wird uns etwas mehr über den
dritten Block erzählen, also wird es eine
Art Experiment geben, nämlich am
13. November 2021 wird es
sozusagen einen Workshop zum Thema KI geben
Praxis wird es eine Präsentation
und Diskussion mit dem Startup Util geben,
vielleicht weiß es jemand von euch, ähm,
das ist das Logo, also was ist YouTube, ich
dachte, es ist ein sehr interessantes Startup
, das KI wirklich
in
die Themen Gleichheit und globale
Gerechtigkeit integriert  Das ist also die kurze Beschreibung
von YouTube. Eine Selbstbeschreibung von ihrer
Webseite. Ich werde sie einfach lesen
Umweltauswirkungen jedes Unternehmens und Portfolios,
daher ist das Ziel dieses Startups wie
folgt: Wir bewerten die Einnahmequellen eines
Unternehmens und ziehen Schlussfolgerungen aus 100
120 Millionen Fachzeitschriften, damit
Sie Zugang zu konsistenten objektiven
Analyseanalysen haben, denen Sie vertrauen können. Wir
unterziehen jedes börsennotierte Unternehmen
weltweit 45.000 davon nach der gleichen
Methodik, damit Sie zwei beliebige vergleichen können
und Zugang zum größtmöglichen
investierbaren Aktienuniversum erhalten, und schließlich
messen wir die positiven und negativen
Auswirkungen jedes Unternehmens auf die 17
unsdgs-
Ziele für nachhaltige Entwicklung
um und Tausende  Nachhaltigkeitsthemen,
damit Sie die
gesamte Wirkung Ihres Portfolios erfassen können.
Wir glauben, dass dies ein interessantes Startup ist, das die
KI-Technologie
sozusagen mit nachhaltigen Entwicklungszielen verbindet
,
um die Welt auf eine Weise zu verbessern, die
wir sehen werden und für die genügend Raum vorhanden sein wird
Diskussion mit diesem Startup haben wir
drei
Mitglieder dieses Startups,
die diskutieren werden  ss unsere Fragen und wir werden uns
auf diesen Workshop vorbereiten, damit ich
denke, jeder von uns wird lernen, wie man
künstliche Intelligenz nicht nur in Bezug auf die
Wissenschaft, sondern auch in Bezug auf Wirtschaft
oder sogar Politik und globale Gerechtigkeit wirklich anwendet. Daher
war dies ein kurzer Zwischenabschnitt
und jetzt übergebe ich dir ehre
für den eigentlichen dritten teil
danke
ich finde
util ist auch irgendwie interessant äh
pause sagen wir
innerhalb des kurses kursplan denn
bis zu diesem punkt
diskutieren wir in gewisser weise sehr
klassisch  oder wir gehen
bis zu diesem Punkt von einer Art klassischer Perspektive auf KI aus,
dass wir in gewisser Weise
bestimmte Maschinen haben, die in der
künstlichen Intelligenzforschung entwickelt wurden, und wir
haben den Menschen,
also nehmen wir an, dass der Mensch intelligent ist.
Nehmen wir an, das ist wahr, und dann
fragen wir, welche Art  Von Maschinen könnten wir
Injektion okay nennen.
Wir beginnen mit einem bestimmten
Verständnis des Denkens des Menschen und
fragen uns, was sich von Ihrer
Denkmaschine unterscheiden würde  Ent
Verständnis des Denkens, aber es ist
jedes Mal, es ist in gewisser Weise eine
Spiegelung zwischen Mensch und
Maschine,
aber tatsächlich haben
viele, viele Anwendungen nicht so viel
oder
sind völlig unabhängig von dieser
Art von Fragen,
weil die
Anwendungen nur
ähm sind  motiviert durch die Ingenieuraufgabe
, die Sie haben,
aus einer Ingenieurperspektive
, die Sie haben, eine Aufgabe,
ein Problem, und Sie versuchen, ein Werkzeug zu konstruieren
oder zu entwickeln
, das Ihnen hilft, die Aufgabe zu lösen,
hat einen wirtschaftlichen Zweck und einen
politischen Zweck, es wird
entwickelt  Zweck entschuldigen Sie mich dafür
und sie versuchen, das Werkzeug zu konstruieren, das
Ihnen hilft, diesen Zweck zu erfüllen,
und sie versuchen, es zu verkaufen, also ist es
ihnen nicht möglich
Fragen Sie, inwiefern ihr Tool intelligent ist
oder was sie
denken, dass
sie nur ein Tool entwickeln, das
funktioniert,
und das ist sehr
weit verbreitet  heute für viele viele maschinelle Lernanwendungen,
aber dies eröffnet
gleichzeitig eine neue Perspektive
auf das, was in unserer
Forschung zu künstlicher Intelligenz und
ihren Anwendungen
passiert, nämlich was passiert, wenn
Menschen und Maschinen
zusammenarbeiten, zusammenarbeiten, interagieren,
in einer sozialen Praxis zusammenarbeiten
,
also deshalb in  Im dritten Teil fragen wir,
wie sich Maschinen verhalten, wenn sie handeln, und
wie sie mit Menschen interagieren,
also
ändern wir ein wenig den Kontext
der Diskussion darüber, dass wir nicht
Mensch und Maschine spiegeln, wir fragen danach, wie
Menschen und Maschinen Menschen tun  Wesen und
Maschinen interagieren,
was ist die soziale Praxis, was ist der
soziale Kontext für eine bestimmte
Interaktion,
wie müssen wir über
die soziale Anwendungspraxis nachdenken, wenn
wir
versuchen, ein Werkzeug für eine bestimmte
Aufgabe zu entwickeln,
damit
wir uns öffnen  das Feld
im Hinblick auf die Praxis und den Kontext
von Anwendungen
und Interaktionen zwischen
Mensch und Maschine in der Realität in einem  Weg
und das ist der ziemlich neue
Ansatz, ich würde sagen, es ist eine Art
nicht-klassischer Ansatz in der Diskussion
über Ai-
Um-Forschung, der von zwei
Philosophen eröffnet wurde, ich glaube, Harry Ah,
Wissenschaftshistoriker, und dem Philosophen Um
Collins und Kush, und der hat  auch
politische und ethische diskussionen oder
implikationen damit
und deswegen diskutieren wir ähm
einen text des ceos und gründers hoven
der sich mit der frage befasst
wie wir
äh waffensysteme sinnvoll kontrollieren können die
irgendwie intelligent sind also
da ist eigentlich die frage wie  wir,
wie wir nicht nur eine Maschine entwerfen müssen,
die intelligent ist, wie wir
das gesamte Anwendungsszenario entwerfen müssen,
damit
wir die
Kontrolle über eine Maschine haben können,
ja, das sind ein bisschen
die
ersten drei
Teile der Vorlesung und wir haben  diese von der
vorlesung des seminars und wir haben diese
drei teile zusammen die eth-studenten
und die elements-studenten
und das ist für alle studenten
aber dann verpflichtend, weil th  die lmu fängt später an
sie müssen auch länger arbeiten
aber nicht
unbedingt auch die itera studenten
denn
am ende des
jahres ist an der eth wie in der ganzen schweiz semesterende
und das heisst
wenn man nicht will
die eth studenten  du musst
dem weiteren programm nicht folgen
das ist ein
obligatorisches programm für die lmu-studenten aber nicht
für die eth-studenten die
trotzdem zur teilnahme eingeladen werden wenn
sie wollen
ja
arnold vielen dank du hast vollkommen recht
also sind egh studenten dazu eingeladen
nimm trotzdem am vierten teil teil, aber
es ist nicht notwendig, weil du getan hast,
was du
tun musstest, aber die lmu-
studenten sind
ich denke wirklich, dass es wichtig für
sie ist, am vierten teil teilzunehmen, also ähm, in
diesem teil werden wir uns
hauptsächlich auf
ähm konzentrieren  verschiedene Anwendungen der künstlichen
Intelligenz, so dass
die ersten drei Teile
sozusagen die konzeptionelle Grundlage und
die philosophische Grundlage sein werden und der vierte
Teil die Anwendung dieser
Konzepte sein wird  Wie wir bisher erfahren haben, werden alle
diese Sitzungen auch aufgezeichnet,
damit die Ath-Studenten es später online ansehen können,
damit sie nicht
sozusagen lebend daran teilnehmen müssen, also am
Seien Sie die Diskussion über
KI und Ästhetik,
also haben
Sie es vielleicht schon gehört. Es gab
einen Versuch, eine von Beethovens Symphonien zu beenden,
seine unvollendeten Symphonien, und ich habe
es mir angehört, und es klang wirklich
interessant,
also werden wir dieses Thema
von ähm
KI und Ästhetik sicherlich diskutieren  Auch Musik gibt es
Sie, wie Sie wissen, es gibt KI, die
malen ähm, die malen kann und so weiter,
also wird das wirklich interessant sein, eine Aufgabe,
bei der die KI eine Art Kreativität hat,
ob sie als eine Art
Agent eines kreativen Agenten betrachtet werden kann  ist die
Frage,
ähm, also werden wir die Woche danach
diskutieren, äh, KI und Autonomie und Robotik,
also wird die Frage sein, ob KI als autonom angesehen werden kann,
ähm, ist es in gewisser Weise ein selbststeuerndes,
selbstbezogenes System und wenn ja, tut es das
eine Art Autonomie besitzen, vielleicht sogar
eine Art moralische Autonomie. Wir werden
die Frage
der Robotik und KI diskutieren, die
im Moment sehr viel ist, also
werden wir in der Woche danach über KI und Posthumanismus diskutieren.
Dies ist eine ziemlich philosophische
Diskussion
so vieler Philosophen  argumentieren, dass ai
die menschheit so aufwerten wird
, dass
eine neue art von menschen entsteht
ich finde diese spekulation
etwas problematisch aber
trotzdem müssen wir darüber diskutieren es
gehört wirklich zu unserem seminar ai und
posthumanismus
so in die  Woche im ersten
Februar am 1. Februar werden wir
endlich ethische Probleme von KI diskutieren,
also wird die Frage ähnlich wie bei der
Diskussion über KI und Autonomie und
Robotik
zuerst sein, ob es äh moralische und künstliche
Intelligenz-Agenten geben
kann, können wir von Agenten sprechen  und wenn ja, sind
sie für das, was
sie tun, verantwortlich zu machen, wenn sie dazu in der Lage sind,
und andererseits werden wir
das Ergebnis von artificia diskutieren  l intelligenz
also macht künstliche intelligenz
unsere welt wirklich besser wir können
diese frage auch mit util
in diesem workshop erörtern aber das werden in
erster linie ethische fragen und probleme sein
die wir in dieser um
session ansprechen und
am 8. februar gibt es schließlich ein Closing
Diskussion, in der
wir alle unsere Erkenntnisse zusammenbringen und
vielleicht auch eine Perspektive auf
weitere Entwicklungen geben können,
und Sie sind auch eingeladen, Ihre
eigene Perspektive in diese letzte
Sitzung einzubringen, um dieses Thema aus einer wirklich interdisziplinären Perspektive zu diskutieren.
Dies ist also der bisherige Kursplan
und wir möchten Ihnen für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit danken und
möchten Sie etwas sagen? ii
möchte eine kurze Bemerkung hinzufügen, bevor
Sie die Möglichkeit haben,
Fragen zum allgemeinen Ansatz
der künstlichen Intelligenzforschung
in diesem Seminar zu stellen
ähm york und ich
wir teilen die meinung ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher,
dass
wir in diesem seminar in erster linie t  Ich möchte
mit Ihnen diskutieren, um gemeinsam mit Ihnen zu reflektieren, wie
wichtig die Relevanz und der
Einfluss der
Forschung
zur künstlichen Intelligenz auf unsere Gesellschaft und auf klassische Theorien
und ähnliches sind, aber wir
interessieren uns in erster Linie für
den aktuellen Stand der Forschung und
Anwendung,
also sind wir in erster Linie interessiert  bei der
Reflexion darüber, was passiert, ähm und möglicherweise,
was in den nächsten Jahren passiert, aber wir
versuchen, ähm, zwei Utopisten, zwei spekulative Fragen zu vermeiden
, die
sehr oft viel älter sind als die
Forschung zur künstlichen Intelligenz, aber damit verbunden sind,
also konzentrieren wir uns nicht auf
Terminator-ähnliche Szenarien wie
Was passiert, wenn
der Schöpfer von der
Macht seiner Kreationen oder ähnlichem überwältigt wird?
Dies sind nicht die Fragen, auf die
wir versuchen werden
, uns zu konzentrieren,
obwohl sie sehr
oft mit der Forschung im Bereich der künstlichen Intelligenz verbunden sind,
manchmal motivieren sie
Forscher möglicherweise,
aber  Dies ist nicht der Hauptfokus des
Seminars, das wir wirklich versuchen zu
sein  aufmerksam zu machen was in der
forschung passiert was
in bezug auf die anwendungen
passiert zu beobachten was passiert und
darüber nachzudenken versuchen zu verstehen was passiert
in konfrontation mit einem aktuellen stand von
forschung und anwendungen und das halte ich vor allem für
einen guten ansatz  für
dieses seminar, wo wir
studenten verschiedener
universitäten zusammenbringen, studenten mit manchmal
eher
geisteswissenschaftlichem hintergrund und einige
studenten hoffe ich zumindest und nach meinem
blick auf die studentenliste habe ich den
eindruck, dass einige studenten einen
starken naturwissenschaftlichen hintergrund
haben  in mathe oder in der informatik
oder in den ingenieurwissenschaften finde ich
das sehr hilfreich
um die ganze diskussion in gewisser weise auf
den aktuellen stand der forschung zu stützen
und die
perspektiven verschiedener disziplinen zusammenzubringen also vielen dank
für diese
verschiebung deiner fragen